HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BREAKING TONIGHT, THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE DEEP
STATES ABUSE OF POWER HAS NOW
COME FULL CIRCLE.
FINALLY.
FOX NEWS TONIGHT CAN CONFIRM,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE FORMER
MI6 AGENT, WHO CREATED THE DIRTY
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WAS IN FACT
GRILLED BY FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
IN JUNE.
THE INTERVIEW WITH STEELE
REPORTEDLY LASTED OVER 15 HOURS.
IT WAS CONDUCTED BY LAWYERS THAT
WERE WORKING FOR THE DOJ'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL, THAT IS
MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
THIS IS 1 OF 2 REASONS THAT THE
IG REPORT IS DELAYED.
THE OTHER BEING KEY WITNESSES
NOW AT THE LAST MINUTE HAVE
FINALLY DECIDED TO COOPERATE.
THIS IS GOING TO GET VERY
INTERESTING BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT: A CRUCIAL DEVELOPMENT
IN THE IG'S INVESTIGATION INTO
FISA ABUSE.
THAT WOULD BE JAMES COMEY, SALLY
YATES, ANDREW MCCABE, AND, YEAH,
EVEN ROD ROSENSTEIN SHOULD BE
VERY WORRIED TONIGHT.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT STEELE'S
DIRTY DOSSIER, BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON, WAS
UNVERIFIED AS A MATTER OF FACT,
UNVERIFIABLE.
FULL OF SALACIOUS LIES, EVEN
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HIMSELF
PREVIOUSLY ADMITTED UNDER OATH
HE HAD NO IDEA WHETHER ANY OF
THE CONTENTS WERE TRUE OR NOT.
WE KNOW "THE NEW YORK TIMES" NOW
SUGGESTING THAT THAT DOSSIER,
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, WAS FULL OF
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION FROM THE
GET-GO TO INFLUENCE THE 2016
ELECTIONS AND MORE.
ROBERT MUELLER, TRYING
UNDERSTAND, MAYBE WE'LL FIND OUT
NEXT WEDNESDAY, WHY DID YOU
END YOUR TEAM HAVE FIND WARFARE
A FAIR ELEVATIONS, LOAN
APPLICATIONS FROM YEARS GONE BY?
TAXI MEDALLIONS, TAXES FROM
YEARS GONE BY?
HOW DID YOU POSSIBLY IGNORE
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES USED TO
GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THE TRUMP
TRANSITION, AND THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY?
OF COURSE, WE ALSO KNOW
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATED
DONALD TRUMP AND HE WAS BEING
PAID A TON OF MONEY -- LETS HE
COME HE IS BEING PAID BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, THE DNC,
THE FBI, AND SOME OLIGARCHS.
GOOD GIG IF HE CAN GET IT.
FOUR PEOPLE PAY YOU FOR LIES.
SO STEELE SPREAD IS B.S.,
ANTI-TRUMP RUMORS TO ANYONE
AND EVERYONE WHO WOULD LISTEN,
INCLUDING HIGH-LEVEL OFFICIALS
IN THE FBI, THE DOJ, OBAMA'S
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, AND WE NOW KNOW
MULTIPLE MEDIA OUTLETS.
EVEN AFTER HE WAS FIRED FOR
LYING AND LEAKING BY THE FBI, HE
WAS STILL USING BRUCE OHR TO
FUNNEL MORE LIES THIS TIME TO
MUELLER AND HIS TEAM OF WITCH
HUNTERS.
BY THE WAY, DID MUELLER USE ANY
OF THIS INFORMATION?
GREAT QUESTION FOR NEXT
WEDNESDAY.
BECAUSE OF STEELE'S RAP AND
BIAS, CONFLICT OF INTEREST, AND
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES A
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES D
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES H
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES S
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES A
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES -
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES L
BLAINE DID PLATED INACCURACIES D
RESEARCH MULTIPLE SERIOUS
WHAT LEGS WERE RAISED BY
OFFICIALS
multiple serious what legs were
AT THE FBI, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, AND MANY, MANY
OTHERS.
THAT DID NOT SEEM TO MATTER TO
JAMES COMEY, THE SUPER PATRIOTS.
HE USED THE PHONY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, FILLED WITH THESE LIES,
AS THE BASIS FOR THOSE FISA
WARRANT APPLICATION.
THAT'S RIGHT, TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE EVIDENCE WAS TRUE AND
ACCURATE, HE SWORE THAT, I AM
TOLD AT THE TOP OF THE FISA
APPLICATIONS AS "VERIFIED."
WE WERE -- WE KNOW IT IS NOTHING
BUT REJOINING US WITH SO MUCH MR
BUT REJOINING US WITH SO MUCH ME
BUT REJOINING US WITH SO MUCH MO
BUT REJOINING US WITH SO MUCH MN
STEELE'S TIME IN THE HOT SEAT,
OUR OWN CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
CATHERINE, ONE THING THAT STANDS
OUT IS IF HE TESTIFIED 15 HOURS,
WE KNOW IN AN INTERROGATORY
UNDER OATH UNDER THE THREAT OF
PERJURY, HE WENT ON THE RECORD
SAYING HE DIDN'T KNOW IF ANYBODY
WAS TRUE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SEAN, GOOD
EVENING.
BASED ON THE REPORTING, THE
FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS CONCERNED
HE WOULD GET "THROWN UNDER THE
BUS" MEANS DR. GENERAL'S REPORT
AND THE APARTMENT OF U.S.
ATTORNEY JOHN DURHAM TO
INVESTIGATE THE ORIGINS OF THE
RUSSIA PROBE RAMPED UP THE
PRESSURE ON STEELE TO A
COOPERATE.
FOX NEWS REPORTED THAT A KEY
WITNESS OUTSIDE THE FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAD AGREED TO
TALK TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL HOROWITZ OF THE 11TH
HOUR AND THAT IT NOW APPEARS TO
BE STEELE.
REUTERS BROKE NEWS THAT HE WAS
INTERVIEWED IN THE U.K. IN JUNE
BY THREE LAWYERS FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
AS WE REPORTED ON YOUR SHOW LAST
NIGHT, THESE LATE-BREAKING
DEVELOPMENTS REQUIRED SOME
WITNESSES TO BE REINTERVIEWED TO
DEACONS LIKE THEIR ACCOUNTS.
CITING ANOTHER POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT DETAIL THAT STEELE
WAS APPARENTLY INTO A BY
INVESTIGATORS WORKING FOR
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
IN SEPTEMBER 2017.
THE NEARLY 500 PAGE REPORT MAKES
NO DIRECT REFERENCE TO THE
SO-CALLED STEELE DOSSIER USED TO
SECURE THE SURVEILLANCE WARRANT
FOR TRUMP CAMPAIGN EIGHT.
THE MUELLER REPORT CALLED THE
DOSSIER INSTEAD, SEE OUR
REPORTING, OR SEAL REPORT,
WHICH HAS THE EFFECT OF
MINIMIZING THE FACT THAT
DEMOCRATS PAID FOR THE
OPPOSITION RESEARCH USED BY THE
FBI AND DOJ TO SECURE THAT
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT IN
OCTOBER 2016 AND THEN THEY USED
IT AGAIN TO SECURE MULTIPLE
RENEWALS, SEAN.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
NOW WE KNOW WHY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS BEEN
DELAYED, INTERVIEWING STEELE
COMMITTEES OF THE PEOPLE COMING
FORWARD, AS PER YOUR REPORT LAST
NIGHT.
GREAT WORK AS ALWAYS,
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IN WASHINGTON
TONIGHT.
IT HAS BEEN SAID, ABSOLUTE POWER
CORRUPTS ABSOLUTELY.
NOWHERE IS THIS MORE OBVIOUS
THAN THE RUSSIAN
MISSION.
BOB   ROBERT MUELLER'S MERRY BAN
BOB   ROBERT MUELLER'S MERRY BAD
BOB   ROBERT MUELLER'S MERRY BAO
BOB   ROBERT MUELLER'S MERRY BAF
DEMOCRATIC DONORS WERE GIVEN A
BIG PLATFORM AND TREMENDOUS
POWER TO INVESTIGATE ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP AND RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
WHILE THEY FOUND NO COLLUSION,
NO CONSPIRACY, NO CHARGEABLE
OBSTRUCTION, THEY DID MANAGE TO
WRECK THE LIVES OF MULTIPLE
PEOPLE THAT WERE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE, WITH STRONG ARM
TACTICS THAT SHOULD MAKE EVERY
SINGLE AMERICAN CONCERNS.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT CONSTITUTIONAL
AND CIVIL LIBERTIES.
BY THE WAY, NOT EVEN WAR HERO
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN, 33 YEARS OF SERVICE, HE
WAS NOT SPARED EITHER.
THE COMBAT THAT FELL VICTIM TO
BOUGHT WAS A PERJURY TRAP.
McCABE, COMEY BRAGGING ABOUT
IT.
HE AND MEMBERS OF HIS FAMILY
WERE THREATENED WITH SIGNIFICANT
PRISON TIME.
HIS SCREWS WERE TURNED IN THE
HOPES THAT HE WOULD SING OR
COMPOSE AS JUDGE ELLIS ONE SIDE
AND IN THE PROCESS MOUNTING
LEGAL BILLS WRECKED HIS FAMILY
FINANCES.
HE HAD TO SELL HIS HOUSE, HE
ULTIMATELY AGREED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO LIE TO THE FBI AND THE
FBI DID NOT THINK HE LIED.
HE DID IT TO SAVE HIS FAMILY AND
IS ON A PARTICULAR.
TONIGHT THANKS TO INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER SARA CARTER, WE ARE
LEARNING SOME DAMNING NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT FLYNN'S PLEA
DEAL AND ACCORDING TO THE LEVEL
COUNSEL, THE EVER SO POWERFUL
AND SMART CINDY POWELL,
PERSECUTORS WANTED FLYNN TO LIE
UNDER OATH AGAINST THE FORMER
BUSINESS PARTNER IN A CASE
SURROUNDING AGAIN A FARA
VIOLATION.
"THE PROSECUTORS HAVE BEEN
ADAMANT THAT MR. FLYNN
TESTIFIED, THAT HE AUTHORIZED
THE FILING OF THIS B6
FORM KNOWING AND ATTENDING THAT
IT CONTAINED FALSE STATEMENTS.
MR. FLYNN CANNOT GIVE THAT
TESTIMONY BECAUSE IT IS NOT
TRUE.
ACCORDING TO SARA CARTER'S
REPORTING, BECAUSE A PLAN IS
REFUSING TO GIVE THE TESTIMONY
THEY ARE DEMANDING THAT HE